de la exclusión de una persona
porque no se enmarca en el patrón establecido,
es la raíz de los problemas de Kenia.
Y está profundamente afianzada.
En 1895, Kenia fue inventada por el colonialismo,
el cual arrasó nuestra identidad
y fundó un sistema de clases construido sobre la otredad.
Es decir que, en 1963, cuando declaramos nuestra independencia,
estas ideas ya eran las normas establecidas.
Desde entonces, hemos hecho lo posible para salir adelante.
Compartimos un mismo idioma, moneda, infraestructura;
básicamente, todo lo que hace que un país sea un país.
Pero todos estos esfuerzos de construir una nación
no van el centro del problema,
que es el siguiente:
no se puede construir lo que no se ama de verdad.
Y no podemos amar
si no nos amamos a nosotros mismos.
Lo que debemos subsanar, como kenianos,
en nuestra falta de amor propio,
nuestro profundo odio por nosotros mismos
y nuestra crisis existencial de identidad.
Y esta tarea de construir una nación
solo puede hacerse mediante la industria creativa.
La idea de que en Kenia solo hay lugar para algunos
me llevó a fundar un festival de música en 2008, 'Blankets and Wine',
que funcionara como plataforma tanto para mí como para otros excluidos.
Diez años después, programamos más de 200 bandas
y pusimos, por lo menos, 100 mil dólares
directamente a disposición de los artistas y los representantes,
quienes, a su vez, los gastaron en técnicos, ensayos,
videos musicales y demás insumos en la cadena de valor de la música.
Nuestra plataforma ha hecho visibles a numerosas personalidades kenianas,
y ha permitido a la industria descubrir y contratar
una amplia variedad de música local.
Lo que hacemos es necesario, pero no suficiente.
Y es imperioso que organicemos un circuito de música en vivo.
Pero la música puede ayudar a la nación de otras maneras.
Según un informe de 2018 sobre los medios,
la radio tradicional sigue siendo el medio de mayor difusión en Kenia,
donde un 47 % la prefieren sobre otros medios.
Esto representa una gran oportunidad.
La radio permitiría a los kenianos escuchar la diversidad que hay en el país.
Se podría reservar un 60 % de la programación radial en Kenia
para transmitir música local.
Podemos derribar barreras étnicas
con la difusión de música keniana producida en inglés, en suajili
y en otros idiomas étnicos,
en una radio étnica que actualmente transmite en un solo idioma.
La radio puede despertar el interés y generar una demanda
de música keniana por parte de los kenianos,
y al mismo tiempo generar los merecidos ingresos
con el pago de derechos de autor.
Pero lo más importante es que la radio puede ayudarnos
a construir una narrativa más inclusiva sobre Kenia.
Porque no se puede amar lo que no sabemos que existe.
Esta tarea también se puede hacer desde otros ámbitos creativos.
Si tenemos en cuenta que el 41 % de los kenianos
aún prefieren la TV sobre otros medios,
es evidente que la industria fílmica tiene un enorme potencial.
Los escasos recursos invertidos en el sector
ya han producido espectáculos de nivel internacional,
como Lupita Nyong'o y Wanuri Kahiu,
pero será necesario contar con más incentivos e inversiones
para propiciar la industria fílmica local,
facilitar el acceso de más historias kenianas a la televisión
y así poner sobre la mesa temas sumamente difíciles
que debemos tratar entre todos.
Habrá que favorecer el surgimiento de más estrellas locales,
y de este modo revertir la idea de que es preciso triunfar afuera
para ser aceptados y valorados en nuestra propia tierra.
La moda también puede ayudar.
Debemos crear las condiciones para producir a gran escala
ropa asequible a los consumidores kenianos
y así dejar de depender de importaciones de segunda mano.
El primer calzado deportivo fabricado en Kenia
tiene que ser un éxito nacional e internacional,
una oda a la excelencia del país,
representada por corredores locales de prestigio mundial, literalmente.
Para que estas ideas se materialicen,
se debe crear empleo,
y las ideas kenianas deben exportarse.
Pero lo más importante
es que nos consideremos, al fin,
merecedores del amor que reservamos para otros.
Nuestra industria creativa es dinámica, es cosmopolita, tiene visión de futuro
y, sin ninguna duda,
es la que forjará nuestro futuro inmediato.
Pero su verdadero poder
radica en su capacidad de reconstruir la idiosincrasia de Kenia,
para lograr, de una vez, construir una nación de verdad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Para esta canción, quisiera que nos detengamos a pensar
en las comunidades de inmigrantes,
especialmente de refugiados inmigrantes
y en la lucha diaria que deben librar
para llevar una vida digna y con sentido,
lejos de lo que han amado y conocido.
Si se sienten identificados con esta idea,
quiero que levanten el puño conmigo.
(Música)
"Un millón de voces"
(Canta)
Vamos, todos, hagan ruido
con un millón, un millón de voces
Con un millón, un millón de voces
No me puedo detener, no me voy a detener
Lo dedico a mi gente que construye
Que trabaja duro para que a sus hijos nada les falte
Cuando los demás la tratan como gente básica
Quiero echarme a reír y decirles que la vean en toda su diversidad
Cuidado, distorsión natural
No nos pueden matar, sobrevivimos hasta el aborto
Dirán que no podemos, verán que sí podemos
Verán cómo llegamos y cuán pronto lo logramos
TED, ¡palmas!
Nunca me es suficiente
Es nuestra única forma de vivir
Trabajando duro, muy duro
TED, hagan palmas así
Nunca me es suficiente
Es nuestra única forma de vivir
Trabajando duro, muy duro
Vamos, todos, hagan ruido
Con un millón, un millón de voces
No me puedo detener, no me voy a detener
Puedo ser tu líder
Puedo ser tu César
Si te muestro cómo hacer más, ¿me prometes lealtad?
Siempre es
tu o yo, o ninguno de los dos
Si te muestro de dónde vengo, ¿me dejarás en paz?
Porque lo que encontrarás, lo que encontrarás
Lo que encontrarás, te lo aseguro, ¡te dejará sorprendido!
Te dejaré sorprendido, muy sorprendido
Y entonces entenderás por qué sigo trabajando duro
Palmas, ¡ahora!
Nunca me es suficiente
Es nuestra única forma de vivir
Trabajando duro, muy duro
Nunca me es suficiente
Es nuestra única forma de vivir
Trabajando duro, muy duro
Vamos, todos, hagan ruido
(Vítores)
(Aplausos)
La letra de la próxima canción incluye algunas partes en suajili,
que es el idioma que hablamos en Kenia.
Trata sobre la amistad entre mujeres
y el poder femenino,
y sobre la unión de las mujeres para construir algo duradero,
un verdadero legado, un patrimonio intergeneracional.
"Suzie Noma"
(Música de percusión)
(Canta)
Sentadas en un rincón
Suzie Noma y yo
No tenemos preocupaciones, parecemos dueñas del lugar
Bebemos Coronas
Miramos el teléfono
Mientras esos chicos apuestos nos dicen cuánto nos desean
Mambo ni kungoja, aki mtangoja
Sinaga matime za kuwaste na vioja
Hacemos planes para tomar el mundo muy pronto
Montadas en los tambores y los aplausos mientras el bajo grita:
¡Ey! Muévete, muévete así
Espera, espera a verlo
Si realmente lo conoces, si quieres mostrarlo
Sigue adelante
Ve a buscar a alguien, mueve tu cuerpo, muéstrale a alguien
Esto lo conozco bien, lo conozco muy bien
Iyo
Maquinando en el rincón
Suzie Noma y yo
Dinero no tenemos, pero hacemos lo que queremos
Nos pintamos las uñas, miramos el correo
Mientras esos chicos apuestos quieren tenernos pero no pueden
Aki mtangoja, leo mtangoja
Saa hii tukoworks hakunaga za vioja
Hacemos planes para tomar el mundo muy pronto
Montadas en los tambores y los aplausos mientras el bajo grita:
¡Ey! Muévete, muévete así
Espera, espera a verlo
Si realmente lo conoces, si quieres mostrarlo
Sigue adelante
Ve a buscar a alguien, mueve tu cuerpo, muéstrale a alguien
Esto lo conozco bien, lo conozco muy bien
Y ahora menea tu cintura
Y ahora haz muecas con la cara
Exagera tus movimientos
Resucita el lugar
Na wale wako fifty fifty comsi
Na wale wako fiti pia sisi
Tuko tu sawa mdogo mdogo yaani
Hallelu-yawa tumeiva design
Si realmente lo conoces, si quieres mostrarlo
Sigue adelante
Ve a buscar a alguien, mueve tu cuerpo, muéstralo a alguien
Esto lo conozco bien, lo conozco muy bien
Iyo
(Vítores)
(Aplausos)